Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers. And this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well, and now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden informed Congress yesterday
that he will officially end
the coronavirus pandemic emergency declaration in May,
which means that everyone can finally
stop wearing their mask a year ago.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden visited New York City today
and spoke about how the bipartisan infrastructure law
will improve the Hudson River Tunnel
that connects New York and New Jersey.
The biggest improvement --
it will no longer connect to New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
The Biden administration unveiled a proposal yesterday
that would make birth control more easily accessible.
That's great. Now can you do razors?
[ Laughter ]
President Biden confirmed last week
that White House chief of staff Ron Klain
will step down in the coming weeks and said,
"The real mark of Ron's success
is that he's beloved by the team he leads."
Though I'd say the real mark of Ron's success
is that this is the first we're all hearing of him.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set to travel to Philadelphia this week
to discuss an infrastructure project
that will replace lead pipes.
But then how are Philadelphians supposed to collect their debts?
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey, people don't want their partners
to earn less than $30,000 a year.
This news first reported
by a guidance counselor to a philosophy major.
[ Laughter ]
"But, like, can you even name one who's working today?"
After vacationing for the last month in Orlando,
former Brazilian president Jair Bolsonaro
has reportedly applied for a six-month visitor visa.
I'm sorry.
You saw Orlando and wanted to stay longer?
[ Laughter ]
"An IHOP and an Applebee's!
Call the consulate and tell them I'm not leaving!"
[ Laughter ]
The U.K. announced plans today to improve its environment
and hopes to restore at least 1.2 million acres
of wildlife habitat to protect rare species
like hedgehogs and red squirrels.
Because if those die out,
it could mean the end of the traditional English breakfast.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
[British accent] "The best we can do is Impossible hedgehog."
Florida law-- [ Laughs ]
Florida lawmakers proposed legislation yesterday
that would allow residents to carry firearms without a permit.
I don't know. I guess they figure
it can't be any more dangerous
than letting 100-year-olds drive.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, according to a new study,
kids missed about 35% of a normal year's worth
of learning during the coronavirus pandemic.
Said kids, "Oh, my God! That's more than half a year!"
And that was the monologue, everybody!